I'm a simple man but if you put a slice
of pizza in front of me I'll be able to
identify it so cold pizza just a yes or
no well cold people the best pizza I
love it I think I like cold pizza better
than I do happy to in some situations
hungover
cold pizza drunk hot pizza I don't think
I've ever eaten cold pizza in my life
what is this is it Domino's
I'm gonna guess it's Papa John's I'm
gonna say it's definitely Domino's this
is Domino's and I know that it's ominous
has to be well Cheers yes Cheers
as I do this is delicious cold it's
sweet the cheese is still good it's
intact the texture of it it kind of
feels like I don't even know how to
describe it
I like it like soft I feel like I just
like eating a sponge coral I don't like
that I have to fight to eat my pizza
right now in terms of leftover pizza
I'll say like a good 7 maybe an 8 I'm
gonna go like 5 oh wow
the dough's like sweet in a way yeah
the crust looks a little bit more
appealing so let's help you today it's
actually good not a lot happening here
oh yeah it doesn't taste like a whole
lot I love all pizza and all pizzas
beautiful the pizzas should know that
but I don't know how I'm feeling about
this one here
I know what this is you know I think I
know what this is yeah I know what this
is already
what is this is Domino's this was like
Little Caesars it smells like garlic
dipping sauce and I love that
I think the garlic on the crash yeah the
crust is fancy crust here oh my god this
is good that's pretty good like garlic
not the crust tastes like a spice rack
in the best way
crust is the most important the breads
most important part of a leftover pizza
I feel like yeah yeah and this is just
this gets it done oh it's all good Allah
does the best tasting coffee to Papa
John's no Pizza Hut oh wow I'm Way off I
mean I do love Pizza Hut but they just
didn't it didn't work today
that was Domino's what that was really
good yeah I know it's king stay king
Papa John's Pizza this is what that is
Papa John's what Donald I'm so sad gotta
give you my phone number I'm wearing
pizza socks and I don't deserve them I
am so disappointed oh I'm so sad I
really love Papa John's it's my favorite
please like my like my favorite pizza
place like I am a Papa John's and to
either
I might start ordering Papa John's
totally leftover pizza is delicious and
anyone who doesn't like cold pizza he
needs to go get a life better
ingredients better leftover pizza
[Music]